Let's review the kinds of timers that are
avaialbe in an operating system, and the Pro's
and Con's. The timer that, many of you may be familiar with is a periodic timer
that is standard in, in most Unix operating
systems. And the periodic timer, the pro is,
periodicity. That's the pro of a periodic timer
that. The operating system is not going to be interrupted
willy-nilly, but it is going to be interrupted
at regular periods. But the con is the
event recognition latency, because the event may have
happened at a particular point in time, but
because of the granularity of the periodic timer.
The event is actually recognized at a much
later point in real time, and that's the
con for periodic timer. And the maximum time
of latency is equal to the period itself, so for instance, if the event happened
just after a periodic interrupt, then the event
will have to be delivered by the next
periodic interrupt. So the worst case latency is
going to be the periodicity of the periodic
timer itself. The other extreme to periodic timer,
is what we call one-shot timers. And what
one-shot timers are, they are exact timers.
That is, you can program these timers to
go off at exactly the point at which you want the entropy delivered. To the
processor, so the pro is a timeliness
of the one-shot timer. And secondly, there is
also fielding these one shot timers as
and which they occur, that's an extra overhead
that the operating system has to deal with.
If you're concerned with the interrupt overhead, one
extreme position to take is to get rid
of timer interrupts all together, and simply use
soft timers. That is, there is no timer
interrupt, but the operating system is going to poll
at strategic times. To see if there is
an external event. What would be strategic times?
Typically any application is going to make system calls. And
when a system call gets you into the kernel,
at that point the kernel can see if there
are any events that need attention at that point
of time. And that is a polling method, but
the downside of the polling method Is the fact
that, there is latency associated with that and there
is also, the fact that, you have to pull
all the events to see if any of them have expired, and there is an
overhead associated with that. These are, the two cons, for a soft timer
but the pro is, the fact that you have reduced overhead for soft timers
since there are no. Timer interrupts, per se, but the kernal
is using strategic points during it's execution
such as system calls or other external interrupts. For instance a network packet
arrival or something like that. As a trigger for looking at the time
related structures to see if any of the events may have expired
at that point of time. Firm timer is a new mechanism that is
proposed in TS Linux and as we will see shortly it combines
the advantages of all the three. Timers
that I just mentioned, the periodic timer,
the one-shot timer, and the soft timer.
Essentially, what firm timer is trying to do
is, take the pros of all of these types of timers in its implementation so
that it can avoid the cons associated with each one of these individual choices.